in the following polynomial identify the
terms along with the coefficient and
exponent of each term so the terms are
just the things being added up in this
polynomial so the terms here let me
write the terms here the first term is
3x squared the second term it's being
added to negative 8x you might say hey
wait isn't it minus 8x and you can just
do that is it's being added to negative
8x so negative 8x is the second term and
then the third term here is seven it's
called a polynomial poly it has many
terms or you could view each term as a
monomial as a polynomial with only one
term in it so those are the terms now
let's think about the coefficients of
each of the terms the coefficient is
what's multiplying the power of X or
what's multiplying the X part of the
term so over here the X part is x
squared that's being multiplied by 3 so
3 is the coefficient on the first term
on the second term we have negative 8
multiplying X and we want to be clear
the coefficient isn't just 8 its
negative 8 it's negative 8 that's
multiplying X so that's the coefficient
right over here and here you might say
hey wait nothing is multiplying X here I
just have a 7 there is no X 7 isn't
being multiplied by X but you can think
of this as 7 being multiplied by X to
the 0 because we know that X to the
zeroth power is equal to 1 so we would
even call this constant this 7 this
would be the coefficient on 7 X to the 0
so you could view this you could view
this as a coefficient so this is also a
coefficient so let me make it clear
these three things are coefficients
coefficients now the last part they want
us to identify the exponent of each term
so the exponent of this first term is 2
it's being raised to the second power
the exponent of the second term remember
negative 8 X X is the same thing as X to
the first power so the
exponent here is one and then on this
last term we already said this is seven
is the same thing as seven X to the zero
so the exponent here on the constant
term on seven is zero so these are these
things right over here those are our
exponents exponents and we are done